by now you've seen the video of that
central park lady who when asked by a
birdwatcher to leash her dog called the
cops on him I'm sure there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like well
that poor dog
she seemed fixated by race you could say
that's part of idea someone to the
police but it sounded more like she was
using it to gin up a false allegation
along with horribly manhandling her poor
dog she became the prime example of what
people call a Karen a person quick to
complain to the manager the dope who
makes his scene about nothing and not
much of a dog owner it backfired she
lost her job and her dog is there any
satisfaction to be found in this maybe
she seems the type who no doubt has
dished out the grief she's getting now
and her mistake isn't small if this
hadn't been filmed the black man could
have been arrested she could have lied
some more and shots could have been
fired instead the phone saved him and
ruined her so is this damage
proportional she is a jerk an oddball
and maybe even a bigot but she
apologized profusely so why not forgive
her because that's what the bird watcher
did of her apology he said quote if it's
genuine and if she plans on keeping her
dog on a leash in the ramble going
forward then we have no issues with each
other now that's not bad if he can do it
so can you and if you don't then you're
kind of being a Karin to a judgmental
person embracing outrage because it
feels good so don't be a bully be the
bird watcher and remember we all have
bad days lucky for us a lot of them
never get filmed Jessie everybody knows
a Karen sometimes people even our
parents are you a Karen sometimes I'm
not gonna answer that stupid question I
will tell you this I'm not crazy about
either of these
people number one the guy's a
birdwatcher I mean how many bird
watchers are in prison right now
probably zero they're the most peaceful
people in the world okay she didn't need
to do that
I guess she shouldn't have played the
race card and called 9-1-1 elise your
dog and get out of there but he he
didn't have to post it on the internet
and ruin her life and apparently he was
like trying to lure the dog with scooby
snax to like teach her a lesson or
something like that I think they should
have a beer summit and just shut up
about this I actually I disagree Katie I
think that he did the right thing he had
to post it because she was going to Chi
could have framed him and also he
actually kinda forgave her cuz he knows
her life is getting ruined I mean I
gotta give him credit well we should all
be more like him I think her behavior
was absolutely absolutely disgusting she
was the one who was breaking the rules
and in general I hate when people who
break the rules and you say something to
them then they act like you're the
problem and that's exactly what she did
here but then she upped the ante ante by
being racist about it and calling the
police even though she was the one who
was in the wrong and it was obvious
because there were signs posted
everywhere so it's unfortunate that she
has faced consequences for this but her
behavior in this situation and as you
said she could have said a whole lot of
things about what was going on he wasn't
threatening her he was just saying hey
could you put your dog on a leash and
follow the rules yeah you know Donna so
here's the big question in my mind she
did an awful thing she's lost her job
and her dog and her reputation does she
just if she's not given a second chance
after an apology then what can she do
aren't we there to give second chances
well look I think mr. Cooper has been
quite gracious he reminded me of the
folks at mother Emanuel who forgave the
man who came in and shot and killed you
know nine people so there's no question
that yes you can forgive that is written
that is something that we all believe as
many of us who are Christian that you
forgive
but here's the biggest story we do live
in an extraordinary time and moment and
when she you know call 9-1-1 with that
voice african-american man maybe we
should just remind her that so many
African American men and women have been
murdered and killed simply because they
exist so I hope people learn something
from this and that we're not talking
about it two three days from now and no
we should not threaten her life and no
she should be able to say I'm sorry and
get back to work at some point Dana his
name is Christian so he could do
something very Christian well I bet you
were disgusted by the way the dog was
handled well I think that if here's what
I would say to all dog owners I know
it's tempting and I've done - you'd let
your dog off the leash but you want to
let them have some freedom if she had
just put the dog on the leash she
wouldn't have been been holding it by
the collar she could have walked away
she would still have her job she would
still have her dog and now the dog
doesn't have as a mom either so it's
it's a terrible situation all around